france is experiencing its worst ever
recorded drought more than two-thirds of
departments in the country are now at
crisis level
and last week the government said around
a hundred towns had completely run out
of water and that means trucks like this
one are coming up and delivering water
so the water is coming through this pipe
going into the building here which
surrounds a borehole which is now
completely dry so eight times a day they
deliver the water which is then pumped
down to the town below
[Music]
you can see here how dry the ground is
so why is the drought so bad well one of
the problems here is that the winter was
drier so there wasn't as much snow on
the mountains there wasn't as much rain
and then the water sources have been
decimated by the long
hot summer so far there are warnings
that some areas could be experiencing
drought until the end of the year
so this is a big problem for lots of
people across france there are water
restrictions in place so in this town
for example you can see the fountain is
off people are limited to using 200
liters per day and they're not allowed
to water their gardens or fill up their
pools for example and they're also
massive issues for farmers some of whom
are seeing a drop in the yields of their
crops
so how do you solve a problem as big as
this well as well as bringing water to
those in need another thing that's being
focused on is re-educating people to get
them to cut down on wasting water so
collecting rain for example but experts
tell us as climate change continues
we're likely to have more extreme
droughts like this